this is truly mindblowing two
individuals whose Hearts been have been
affected by this Hamza chamay but in the
case you are an animal and and you went
out there and did your job tonight and
Dave Chappelle you're you're a Muslim I
am when did you become Muslim when I was
17 what were the circumstances I that
was like believing in God and stuff so
just recently what we've seen we've seen
Hamza chai after his victory in the UFC
coming out guys you know what's
happening in the world now right now I
wasn't happy in the cage fight this week
oh see the kids dying it doesn't matter
whatever in the world Ukraine
and when kids die it's hard guys you can
see the sadness that's overtaken him
from seeing these innocent children
being
massacred because the people in the
palan sign on SE they don't have nothing
they Clos them and attack them every day
they not kill some terrorist or some
like people they kill the kids old
people you know this is a crazy and what
we have from Dave Chappelle allegedly
this is coming out from the Washington
Post here's how it went down per the
attendees Chappelle condemned the acts
of October 7 but said it was wrong for
students to lose their job offers over
their support for Palestine this
prompted an audience remember to shout
shut the f up Dave this is what
triggered more of a reaction from
Chappelle according to the attendees he
said the attacks were not an excuse to
cut off water electricity some people in
audience cheered and shouted free
Palestine While others yelled what about
this group the couple of attendees say
Dave also said free Palestine but other
say in the crowd that he didn't they
didn't hear him say that we have this I
I guess this is from one of the
attendees saying something in America is
changing I saw Dave Chappelle last night
at the Boston Garden it was sold out so
Dave Chappelle is in front of 22,000
people 34s in the show 34s into the show
he said I want to address what's going
on in Palestine and Israel then he said
also what's going on isn't right and not
just but also what's going on obviously
with the massacre of the innocent men
women and children there in Gaza is not
right right you can't kill innocent
civilians like that and the whole world
sits silently and watches then someone
shouted at him from the crowd again shut
the up da then went nuts and yelled back
no you Dave shabelle went out to say you
don't take tens of billions from my
country to go kill innocent women and
children and then tell me to shut the up
he said don't come begging for money
from my country and then go drop bombs
on children cut off innocent people from
water and electricity you have the
audacity to pay to come see me and tell
me to shut up he goes on to say the
crowd started clapping and cheering for
him saying yes Dave and chance of free
Palestine and then he said you're damn
right free Palestine he went on a
15minute rant about being a Muslim and
that Israelis are pro projecting what's
wrong with them on Muslims and the crowd
kept on cheering it was surreal crowd
was typical Boston demographic so this
is true if this is accurate de Chappelle
taking a stand being affected obviously
what's going on people are watching the
mainstream media they're not really
getting the full picture so he's
probably seeing all of the images of
innocent men women and children there
it's a complete Massacre and then you
have Hamza chamai also you can see let's
go ahead and take a a listen to him
right after his about what he had to say
I see the kids dying you know so that's
that's that's that's hard there a lot of
things in my heart so sorry guys okay
thank you P so you can see the
mainstream media as if they're reading a
script as if it's passed down to them
and they got a script there certain
points they go by and that's said they
don't deviate from that it's like they
have an agenda they're pushing it
anybody who questions it they try to
cancel the propaganda narrative is so
deeply ingrained and enforced
that if you refuse to go along with the
narrative if you won't say the words
that they want you to say if you express
your thoughts differently than what is
allowed just listen to Fox News CNN Ms
they're all saying the same things and
that should give you a warning right
there and if you say anything different
than what fox and NBC and CBS and all
the other networks are saying then you
are you're vilified you're not allowed
to speak you're not qualified to speak
you shouldn't be even allowed to open
your mouth that's the attit but these
two are brave enough stepping up and
speaking on behalf of the children on
behalf of the innocent innocent human
beings this is this is something that
should really awaken us and have us to
ask ourselves where are we if we're
people of God if we're people that now
believe in a higher power you think God
Almighty is going to stand with the
oppressors with the unjust to go ahead
and sanction something like this even
though you have people even trying to
justify
there is no mercy you may think you're
being merciful to a child but you're not
being merciful to the child you're being
vicious to the ultimate victim that this
child will grow up and
kill because the
ideology that child will grow up
with is even worse than the ideology of
of his
father hence the reason why the Torah in
the book of Deuteronomy CH 20:
says rules of
War do not allow anyone to remain alive
nothing no
mercy
furthermore the book of Deuteronomy 25:
completely
erase any memory ofik which means men
women and children the T says do not
have the right to exist as I started
this is truly mindblowing but it's nice
to see people like this while people are
paying celebrities to go ahead and to
advertise every day it was just nonstop
you were cucking for the Israeli
government yeah but I wish I hadn't gone
really you have these people doing this
for free because they're seeing they're
seeing is affecting their hearts seeing
these innocent
children
no being massacred it's truly just
mindblowing heartbreaking commend both
of them for taking center stage and
creating some awareness to this being a
voice for the voiceless we'll see you
next time until then peace be with you
assalamu alaykum brothers and sisters
we've all had loved ones that passed
away a mother a father a brother sister
a close family member but one of the
mercies of our Dean is that with the
right intention we can go ahead and
continue to do good deeds on our loved
ones behalf and what greater of a
continuous Good Deed s than investing on
their behalf in the dean Center a mid
and mega dawa Center that will benefit
generations to come inshallah so click
the link below donate right now may God
Almighty Allah reward all of you I
cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you're not yet Muslim and you tuning
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go ahead and visit theen show.com
we'll take care of the Postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about Islam call US at800
66247 52 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaykum